>> Tucker: FORMER TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ADVISOR GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS REPORTED TO JAIL
TODAY.
SERVING A 14 DAY SENTENCE.
SUPPOSEDLY THAT SENTENCE IS
NECESSARY SO ROBERT MUELLER CAN
PROTECT THE REST OF US AND
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY ITSELF FROM
THE MORTAL THREAT OF A
OPERATIVES HIDING IN THE BUSHES.
IS THERE A SINGLE PERSON IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHO
BELIEVES THAT?
AND IF THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT,
IF THEY KNOW IT'S A LIE, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY IT IS, WHAT IS THE
POINT OF PUTTING GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS BEHIND BARS OR ANY
OF THESE PEOPLE?
MANY ARE BEING RUINED, THEIR
LIVES DESTROYED BY THE
INVESTIGATION, IS IT ACHIEVING
ANYTHING?
IS A PART OF A PARTISAN
VENDETTA?
WHAT IS THE POINT MET SIMONA
PAPADOPOULOS JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOUR HUSBAND IS NOW BEHIND BARS,
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR ON THIS, IS
THERE EVIDENCE THAT HE WORKED
FOR THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO
SUBVERT OUR DEMOCRACY?
>> THANKS FOR INVITING ME.
TONIGHT I FEEL A LOT OF EMOTION
EMOTIONS.
MOSTLY I FEEL DEFEATED AND
SCARED.
SCARED NOT ONLY FOR THE 14 DAYS
OF JAIL TIME, BUT MOSTLY BECAUSE
IT IS COMPLETELY GROUNDLESS AND
BASED ON CONTACT WITH THE
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS.
I ALWAYS STRESS AND HAVE BEEN
VERY VOCAL ABOUT THE PLEA
AGREEMENT.
HE WALKED TODAY INTO THE JAIL
WITH A LOT OF COURAGE AND
RESILIENCE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I FEEL THIS
DECISION IS VERY UNFAIR.
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE DECISION
OF THE JUDGE, ABOUT THE
INCRIMINATING THINGS FABRICATED
BY MUELLER.
WE KNOW TODAY, EVIDENCE JUST
CAME OUT RECENTLY ABOUT ZERO
LEVEL OF INVOLVEMENT IN THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION SCHEME.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND, HONESTLY
HOW MISREMEMBERING THE DATE OF
THE MEETING WITH A PROFESSOR
COULD LEAD TO HIS JAIL IN
WISCONSIN WHERE I WALKED IN IN A
VERY STRESSFUL WAY.
I FEEL HE DID.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY AS A WHOLE
IS UNDERMINED.
I THINK THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN
TO ANY CITIZEN.
BEING DESTROYED AND ASSASSINATED
IN THIS WAY BECAUSE TODAY THERE
IS THE STIGMA ON THE REPUTATION
FOR BEING A TRAITOR.
HE NEVER BETRAYED ANYONE.
HE SIMPLY DIDN'T BELIEVE
INFORMATION THAT MUELLER WAS
TRYING TO EXTORT FROM THEM SO
TALK ABOUT HIS POINTS, IT IS MY
STRONG BELIEF, IT LOOKS TO ME AN
AWKWARD SITUATION THAT PUT ON
HIS LIFE AND ALSO MY LIFE.
I PROFOUNDLY BELIEVED IN HIM AND
HIM A PERSONAL WITNESS OF THE
CASE.
I KNOW HE IS NOT A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
I'VE KNOWN THIS MAN FOR FIVE
YEARS AND I CAN UNDERSTAND HOW
THE MEETING WITH THIS PROFESSOR
COULD LEAD TO INCARCERATION
TODAY.
>> Tucker: HE VOLUNTEERED TO
HELP THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN HIS REAL
CRIME.
WE SHOULD CARE IF AN INNOCENT
MAN GOES TO JAIL, EVEN FOR TWO
WEEKS, AND NOBODY CARES AND WE